foreign
welcome back our next guest shot this
video of the new floating barrier at a
portion of the Border in Rio Grande
Texas as a legal Crossings hit record
highs the floating border is now the
state's latest effort to curb The Surge
Lieutenant Chris Oliveira is with the
Texas Department of Public Safety joins
us now good morning to you thank you so
much for joining us
you have seen firsthand there's about a
thousand I think a thousand feet of this
Marine border that's going in at
Governor Abbott's order tell us a little
bit about what you're seeing
so I just got back from Eagle Pass Texas
that's where the Marine bear is going to
be placed and just another example of
Texas and of course Governor Abbott
taking historic action trying to use
every tool and strategy in place to
secure the border now the purpose of
this Marine barrier is to prevent and
discourage any unlawful Crossings taking
place the river is very dangerous we
recovered numerous bodies just during
the Fourth of July holiday we recovered
four bodies including an infant from
drowning so we want to discourage anyone
thinking about Crossing that River so
that they can go to a port of entry and
seek Asylum and also to prevent
Smugglers criminals that are taking
advantage of these monuments that are
crossing the river extorting them for
money robbing them for money or any
other personal belongings and that way
they cannot bring people across the
river so it's another added layer of
Defense to what we have in place already
with razor wire boots on the ground uh
boats in the water so it's all too
discourage and deter any potential awful
Crossings at that River when you hear
politicians or other people who are
criticized sizing this new Marine border
is you've just mentioned there were four
deaths last week one including an infant
do you think that people are putting
politics over human life
absolutely that's one thing I was going
to mention right now you know we don't
we don't see any of the you know
pro-immigration activists or anyone
criticizing the fact that we have bodies
that are you know people that are
drowning in the river that we that we
have recovered or people that are dying
because of the heat exposure uh and
people that are actually crossing the
river itself I mean that's not a that's
not a legitimate way to seek Asylum by
crossing a river
um especially with children but yet you
don't hear any criticism from anyone on
that you don't see anyone else at the
front lines jumping in the river to
rescue migrants or even or even
arresting Smugglers that are taking
advantage of these migrants but the ones
that are doing it is our law enforcement
Personnel our DPS Personnel our border
patrol agents they're on the front lines
they're out there every single day in
115 degree weather jumping in the river
rescuing migrants arresting Smugglers
but no one else is doing it and of
course we're going to continue to find
strategies and and move forward that's
not going to score just from what we're
doing we have a job to do we have to
protect our state our country and that's
what we're out there every single day
doing the job well and we thank you so
much for that we have a 2024 election
coming up what is your message to the
new president
we have to put the policies in place we
have to apply consequences uh we got to
discourage any type of mass migration
taking place so put policies in place
that were working prior to 2021 start
the border wall construction and now
Texas has set this Foundation now with
this first ever Marine barrier let's
continue with those efforts and places
bury along the river so we can secure
our border and prevent any other
unlawful Crossings and also to go out to
the criminal organizations in Mexico the
drug cartels to take away their profits
and prevent the the flow of federal
that's coming across our border that's
killing tens of thousands of Americans
every single day certainly is Lieutenant
Chris oliveras Texas DPS thank you so
much